hey what's up guys my name is Jenna
welcome back to my game engine series
feel sore good to say that it's been so
long since the last episode I am now
married so finally we can get back to
this game engine am i right that's what
all have you've been thinking I mean I'm
very happy with the wedding everything
went really really well and all of that
can't say that the game engine was on my
mind but it is now so we're gonna get
right back into it and we're finally
gonna start on the rendering because I
feel like rendering whether the huge
kind of thing that I was waiting to do
and didn't have time but now I've kind
of got a lot more time so we're going to
just jump right on into this and begin
our journey to creating a render up for
hazel first of all just want to give a
huge thank you to all the patreon
supporters that actually made this
series possible you can head on over to
patreon and conversation the churner and
help support the series there you'll get
stuff like access to the source code
that I've already written for hazel
which is kind of my own private
development branch version of hazel
looks a lot more advanced than what you
see here and like very very many videos
essentially ahead and you'll also get
access to a private channel so you can
talk to me and do a whole bunch of other
stuff so huge thank you as always for
those people who are generous enough to
support this series okay so rendering
the first thing that we need for our
rendering we kind of went over the
rendering architecture of hazel if you
guys haven't seen that video definitely
check that out
last episode as well was the call kind
of making hazel into a static library
and cleaning everything up I'm really
really happy that we did all that
because now I mean this compiles with
zero warnings everything is just ready
to go it's a static library it's all
kind of just ready for us to continue
development and that's a really good
state to kind of be in for something as
big as the renderer and I mean as much
as I'd like to just write a renderer
from start to finish there's obviously
going to be exhilarating stuff that we
kind of do like I will probably at some
point I'd want to write some I'm GUI
kind of widgets or just like maybe even
use this kind of docking library that we
have and I am going to create somewhat
of like an editor or an interface it's
not gonna be like bang let's just go
from nothing to having like a full kind
of PR deferred renderer that does
everything in post-processing and
everything just kind of without taking a
break that there are going to be bits in
which I'm like a cable now let's focus
on something else so I just don't want
you guys to be too disappointed if that
happens I'm going to write this renderer
as I would write a renderer there's not
going to be any kind of like
modification that I'm doing just because
this is a video series I'm just gonna
kind of do it my way
and hopefully that's kind of something
that you guys will be into but we'll see
obviously I'm always open to feedback
and the comments section is really
important to me I mean I used to just
like look at dis and copy the code that
I wrote earlier but clearly you guys
didn't like that so I now write all the
code live to the point where I actually
don't even know what code I want to
write today but hopefully it's gonna be
good anyway enough chitchat let's talk
about what we're actually doing today so
the first thing that we need for a
renderer is a context we need a
rendering context now we have rendered
have we rendered a triangle and OpenGL
in hazel before I don't actually know
cuz I don't remember but we need a
rendering context again that rendering
architecture video is really useful and
kind of cover the reason I keep talking
about it is because it kind of covers
the fact that we need a rendering API
like a renderer and then a rendering API
light right this is part of the
rendering API this is something that's
going to be different for each renderer
that we actually use or for each API
that we use so by API I mean things like
OpenGL DirectX development that kind of
stuff right and we need to wait a credit
context for that API so in OpenGL it's
really really simple and in fact gfw
handles pretty much all of it for us
it's super simple for Vulcan it's a lot
more complicated like everything else is
right we need to create apart from like
doing things like picking the logical
and physical device which means just
picking which GPU to use and then
creating like a and I'm a Vulcan side
device for it and all that stuff we also
need to create things like the swap
chain this this is a lot more simple
because we're dealing with OpenGL to
begin with don't worry we will get
developing hazel will support Vulcan at
some point in the future and we'll kind
of cross that bridge when we get that
but for now in OpenGL it's dead simple
so I'm not going to create a billion
classes right now our billion files to
kind of do
different abstracted things until we
actually need to but I will create an
OpenGL context kind of file which will
contain everything that OpenGL needs to
actually render things and we're gonna
kind of decide how we abstract that away
from basically the window class in which
it can't it kind of lives there right
now um because obviously we have written
the kind of context creation and also
this watch and code what else is there
to say really I just want to jump into
hazel right now and take a look at if we
have a triangle if we can get a triangle
on the screen and then we'll start
actually kind of stripping that code out
and creating our context class and we'll
kind of talk about why we're doing that
and how it's gonna work as well so let's
just jump on over into the code and see
what we have
alright so this is the window class this
is the windows window class to be more
specific
so inside our initialization code we
kind of have these three lines right we
have this make context current if we
look at what that actually does you'll
see that based basically this winter has
a context class right this is very
similar to what we're actually doing now
we've got a winter class that's kind of
our you know Windows window in this case
but then what we don't have and what we
need and what the purpose of this
episode is is to create this context
class and this context class is gonna
basically contain context specific so
graphics kind of rendering context
specific so in other words OpenGL
specific in a sense code right so this
window context make current again is
something that yep W will do based on
the context that you're using it could
be OpenGL shelf so view also supports
the Vulcan
that's essentially what that will do it
will just kind of take the window handle
and then set that window handle as the
rendering target or context for the
rendering API that we're actually using
and jela dolly will kind of do that for
us so that we don't actually have to
touch like windows specific code to set
up an OpenGL kind of context - same with
Vulcan as well instead of kind of
retrieving certain pointers from the
Vulcan dll's to set this up for Windows
and that's you know done via essentially
catch our extensions Chronos extensions
instead of doing all that stuff kind of
does it for us which is great for Vulcan
we probably will use jewel of W as well
although
in my kind of own personal Vulcan
projects I've always done everything
manually so will will say again as I
said we'll cross that bridge when we get
there
we're doing open gel for now because
it's it's the most simple API to use and
then there's swap buffers right which is
a swap chain I'm talking about again
super simple it does it for us right so
we essentially need to call this line of
code and this line of code but I don't
want to do it from the window I want to
do it from the actual context class and
you might be like why why are we doing
that if gfw already abstract stuff for
us why are we adding another layer of
abstraction the reason is this is
definitely not all we want to support
jela probably supports OpenGL and Vulcan
which is fantastic but what we actually
need is also support for DirectX and
metal right possibly even other API is
if we like I don't know go onto the ps4
or anything I want to kind of future
proof this basically is what I'm saying
DirectX 100% be supported metal as well
almost definitely but way further down
in the future so because of that we
can't just have gel W make contacts
current here right because this implies
that every window is window that we ever
make will initialize they shelved on the
context shelf so V context means that
it's going to be either open jail or
Vulcan so how on earth from this code do
we say we want a DirectX context we
can't write and that's a problem which
is why this needs to be abstracted out
into a class that we're gonna call
OpenGL context essentially and then this
of course also loads OpenGL kind of
extensions right again not something
that needs to be done for DirectX off of
even for Vulcan so this stuff is really
kind of API specific and that's kind of
a goal it's gonna be to kind of move
that stuff out and create it and kind of
put it into its own class which again
will the implementation of that class
will be dependent on which API will
actually pick and also I mean api's are
gonna be picked at runtime as well right
so at runtime we'll be able to decide on
Windows for example if we want OpenGL
Vulcan or DirectX since that platform
sports all three and then if we scroll
down a bit and on in on up there we've
got Paul events which is great but then
we've got swap buffers again this is
kind of the window on update function
this is when we want to refresh our
window
so that's not something that really kind
of you know this shelf Obispo Perez is
not something that we really do for you
know indirect tax or metal or whatever
we're using I mean it's not gonna be
metal right because this is windows
window but anyway for DirectX not
something we want it'll be completely
different right so because of that we
need to we can't just do gel W swap
buffers we need to essentially do
something like M context you know not
swap offers now this might even be
something like you know if we wanted to
really be cool it might have even been
contacts now it gets
WAP shame and then you know flush or I
don't know it might be the API will
probably change over time especially if
we decide to implement Vulcan as it's
like kind of not a through gel view kind
of route because that does simplify
things but we'll see you know in that
case we might have to do stuff like
there's essentially and we might have to
set up abstractions for all the api's to
be able to do that but for now I think
that's pretty good context you know swap
buffers kind of makes sense and it's
clearly gonna touch the swap chain so
I'm pretty happy with this kind of API
for now so we'll kind of just leave that
there just so that we can fill in the
blanks in a minute I'm here as well
pretty simple it could definitely be
something like context equals new OpenGL
context and now that will kind of just
create the context there I don't
actually want to do that there I'm
actually going to the context is
probably gonna be a stock variable that
just gets initialized automatically and
may perform some checks to make sure
it's actually valid I'm just thinking
about how I want to do this mmm now
having a stack variable probably isn't
the best thing to do since it will
actually need to be kind of polymorphic
in the sense that like we might have a
derived class that is depending on the
API that we actually choose there's also
gonna have to be some kind of context
selection so I think that ultimately
speaking context will most likely be
just a pointer in which case we'll just
we'll leave an arrow here for now
context might even be something that's
static
yeah the ownership of contacts is
something that we haven't really thought
about that's kind of important because
you know it should the window
essentially own the context that's
that's one way of doing it if we look at
window I usually like doing that having
the window earn the context I think I've
done that and pretty much everything
I've ever written but I still do like
the context to be something that is
static because it's not something that
you know a rendering context you almost
always have one of them at least per
window right you're not gonna have
multiple rendering contexts just trying
to think I mean there are advanced
things you could do that there's always
things that you can do right I just want
to make that clear if I just pop back
from the screen to the camera to even
say this there are always things that
you can do that you might want to kind
of modify this design for I want to kind
of make that explicit as well designs
that we decide on right now are not
going to be final they're gonna be
liable to change just like anything ever
one thing I can think of is some
scenarios is you you might you might
want to do something like have a window
and then inside that window have like
kind of a split view maybe and then half
of its being rendered using DirectX half
of its being rendered using Balkin
that's something that the people have
done before in fact EA is kind of
Halcyon like is the seed kind of
research engine that EA has is a public
kind of PowerPoint presentation that I
can link in the comment section below if
people are interested more in the
description that that's something that
for example does DirectX and valve and
rendering at the same time in the same
kind of frame like in the same window as
side by side so that they can as they
developed you know Vulcan for example
they can kind of compare it easily to
the direct export render and see if
there are any kind of discrepancies
between the tree rendering kind of
visuals essentially so there are always
things that you can do like that might
break this design but for what we're
doing right now at least I feel like a
contact having a static context is
pretty reasonable what you're going to
do in hazel is you're going to kind of
open up a window you're gonna create a
in context for say DirectX and that's it
you really don't have any reason to
change if you do have a reason to change
you're going to basically recreate the
whole thing right so you're gonna be
like I'm going to tear down my window
then I'm gonna create a new window which
might use Vulcan or something like that
right and maybe in that in that sense
you could even have two windows open
that would use that but again just to
keep things simple for now because we
could spend hours discussing this in
fact we've already been discussing this
a lot but I think that what we really
should do and could do for now is just
basically keep it simple and say that we
have a window we have a rendering
context that's it we have one rendering
context that's what you use to render in
hazel it's one context dumb ok let's get
back into it ok so that's what I'll kind
of do for now I think and then we can
also create kind of a static interface
to that context so that we can access it
from anywhere in the future but what I
will do for now is inside windows window
I will probably create essentially some
kind of rendering context so we'll say
rendering context mmm I'm not even sure
what to call this because probably a
graphics context will make it a pointer
and context right and then this is
something that return windows a window
in it
you know meet we might want to say at
this point in time based on a property
even you could define it but what I'm
gonna do is you say that the rendering
context right now it's going to be a new
OpenGL context or a graphics context
OpenGL we can just call it OpenGL
context it was obviously going to be
graphics um I'll put that onto the poor
infer this doesn't it doesn't really
matter what's line of code it's gonna be
because I'm not gonna do anything in
this initialization like in this
constructor we're not gonna do anything
so it doesn't matter if it's really
before or after jail of W we might want
to put it after but not really that
important because over here is where
it's actually going to be initialized
and that's where we're going to do the
following code right so this now kind of
belongs inside that line of code right
and then we're gonna do all that and
then obviously we're gonna do this what
buffers thing which is going to be
inside contact
right over here okay so now we're pretty
much done let's go ahead and create that
so what I want to do is in inside you
know well let's just make sure we're in
show of files yep we don't actually have
anything to do with the rendering so
I'll add a new folder called renderer
and then inside there I'm gonna make a
header file called graphics contacts dot
H we're gonna obviously put this into
the hazal namespace graphics contacts
and then inside opengl I'm also going to
create a new item and I had a file it's
gonna be called OpenGL contacts and then
we're going to also create a C++ file
which is called OpenGL contacts that's
going to include our PCH and the OpenGL
context file name space hazel just copy
that put it into the header file class
OpenGL context public graphics context
maybe we should have called the
rendering context because the renderer
anyway I really could not care less
about names right now we might change
change them depending on my kind of mood
but we'll just say this is gonna be in
hazel Brannon Road rap this contest cool
so that's our context essentially that
we could probably could just keep it
cold we could is called context um puts
office inside the renderer but because
we're not using namespace is like a
renderer I thought it'd make more sense
to actually call it a graphics context
this is gonna be again just a normal
kind of interface which will have to
send things like in this and also
probably swap buffers very very bland
for now I'll make these things your
virtual right very bland for now very
simple we're gonna keep it as simple as
we need to because well first of all
rendering can get complicated in math
and I want to try my best rather serious
kept as simple as possible right but
also because OpenGL really is
simple now especially with GL of W so
this obviously is going to overwrite
this stuff now here's the thing clearly
when we create something like a note
from your contact we're going to need
some kind of handle to the window so
that we can actually control things
right basically we're gonna just take in
a gel W window handle and I'm actually
going to do this from the constructor
okay so the constructor is just kind of
going to underscore this job double
window the constructor or maybe we can
just pull this window handle for now
that way if we change from gel W will
still be a window handle it's kind of
kind of makes sense so basically what
I'm saying and what I might do is just
make a forward declaration watch it off
W window here so we don't have to
include it so basically what we're gonna
do here is just set that property and
window handle all right that's what
we're gonna do in the constructor which
also means that we need to go into
windows wind over here I'll include our
context renderer graphics context
hazal do that there this thing I'll
include in OpenGL context LCVP I don't
know why it's not toggling between
header file and it's a file but anyway
so we've got the constructor we've got a
neat this is OpenGL context we can
remove the pure virtual stuff and add
that it's an override and then from our
from our actual window let's not just
open that we don't need from our actual
window that's where we're actually going
to set our window so M window and
obviously we're going to do that after
we actually create the window so it'll
create the context and then we'll
initialize that context
okay so OpenGL context it's not happy
with that
so got graphics context and then over
here what we will use hazel or platform
where is it it's not it's just platform
is it yeah
platform OpenGL OpenGL context alright
cool
that should make most things go away
here all the arrows yeah cool
alright and that's pretty much it so we
have the window and now we can kind of
do everything we need and that looks
pretty good to me
so we'll cop we'll grab this line of
code we'll go into in it which I guess
we haven't created yet and we will just
put that in there so let's actually make
all of this stuff yeah it really doesn't
think that how I oh of course I miss
belt it well I would that's why gone
text I wonder how long you guys were
watching that full before you realize
how stupid that was
you're probably yelling at your screens
thing like what are you doing Jonah
okay great mantid implementations and
then obviously here the anything were
really going to do is window handle
winter handle open jail context in its
gonna do that this is the window handle
and then glad we also need glad so one
of the things we've done here is we've
removed a vigil dependencies right so
glad it's not open glad is open jail
specific gel Toby isn't but Gladius so
that's another thing that we've kind of
taken or now removed from window so
there's nothing really the ties it
specifically token jail anymore because
this stuff kind of happens here which is
really cool and then we'll also go into
windows window and then take that swap
buffers code that we had and actually
move it into here into swap buffers
alright really easy and then window
handles obviously what we have over here
um and we could do things like assert to
make sure that that window handle
actually exists so you know window
handle
handle is not visible what to do some
basic checking if we wanted to but I
honestly think that this is really dead
simple and we don't really need to add
anything to make it super complicated
okay cool
now that was something else I feel like
I wanted to address but I don't really
remember okay well this is an error what
actually is the structure of this since
that source we do have platform OpenGL
and then yeah not gone text context okay
cool let's build everything see if we
get any errors or warnings or anything
and then we can run it and hopefully
it'll work okay so we do get warnings
type notepad Santa Claus says he's
struck yep that's because when we even
get um well yeah I probably misspelled
something here context maybe not that's
all anyway this should be struct that'll
solve that warning um and then what's
this it's not found I can't find
something to do with that
I was build again okay we're fine maybe
it was to do with the struct thing um
let's just run see what we get there you
go all right cool so we have this going
on here you know we could do something
like inside swap offers if we really
wanted to test it out we could may you
try to notice to work in our guarantees
that we could maybe try some immediate
murder to jail which you know I don't
even know if it'll let us do that um
let's just do that early no compile wow
it really doesn't compile
right now I don't know what we can do
here the stuff doesn't that's really
quite interesting isn't it
this subject exists what's in here GL
dot H which I thought I included but
apparently I didn't I was gonna try and
do some stuff the other thing we could
potentially do I don't know if this will
work though is we could try and create a
vertex buffer with some data and then
see if you can render it automatically
but yeah kind of wished immediate mode
we'll just we'll just work for us but
apparently it just doesn't are so
interesting that it just does not
whatever knew it included that's
probably a good thing I mean it probably
wouldn't work anyway because we're using
the core profile but anyway my point is
that this should actually now be payable
rendering just like it was before we
don't really have any test with I mean
you can see that the clay color is pink
that's compromising and if you're
wondering the clear color will be
controlled by the actual renderer class
not by the context or anything like that
and in fact to be a little bit more
specific this whole GL clear thing which
right now actually is happening inside
application this whole thing will
technically be happening on a frame
buffer so we'll have like a rendering
buffer essentially a frame buffer that
will just be our screen right and then
that will contain things like clear
commands and that's gonna be the
architecture of that anyway that is
pretty much the context class really
simple again for OpenGL but now the big
thing that we've achieved here is we've
we're creating a rendering context and
it's completely you know independent
here I mean we have our pijl context we
should be able to just say hey I wanted
a direct tax context just like that and
guess what all it does is it takes in
the window handle all it does is in it
and swap offers right
that Direct X also needs both of those
things we can just have a different
implementation and suddenly we have
Direct X and then obviously maybe in
window props in the future when we have
multiple api's we would have something
along the lines of like m data you know
api or something
Propst OPI and then based on that we
could maybe do like a switch or
something and decide or maybe even ahead
of time that instead of using an OpenGL
context we would use a DirectX one or
anything else hope you guys enjoyed that
video if you didn't hit the like button
you can also help support the stairs by
going over to patreon a conversation the
chair a huge thank you as always to all
the wonderful people that make this
series possible next time we're gonna
move on and start creating the renderer
class right that's going to be something
that's gonna be probably designed and
redesigned a billion times but
essentially we need that for things like
the clear color we need that for issuing
rendering commands right we need that
for state we need that to so many things
and we're probably gonna we might even
have a bit of a design episode next time
I'm not really sure at this point I
still have a few things in my life that
I need to sort out at this point in time
because making some changes but yeah
essentially next time I think we're
gonna start off with around or unless I
kind of realize that something else is
important that at this point in time I'm
kind of I forgotten about but anyway I
hope you guys enjoyed this video I hope
you guys are as happy as I am to be back
into hazel way into this series I will
see you next time goodbye
[Music]